I'm actually quite good about taking
time for myself where I disconnect from
everything you know I'm a great believer
you know when people take vacation but
they're online the whole time that's not
a vacation that's telecommuting from a
beach right and so one could argue that
in our modern day and age we actually
take zero vacation and we have zero
evenings and zero weakness and I think
that's incredibly unhealthy and so as a
company and as an individual we're
pretty good like if I get emails on a
weekend if I look at them which I don't
always I will not reply until Monday
because it's the weekend you know
there's always exceptions and when I go
on vacation I tell my team I'm on
vacation if there's an emergency deal
with it cuz I'm on vacation and quite
frankly any anybody who goes to a
retreat or an off-site or it takes a day
off and checks in on a regular basis
nothing nothing says I don't trust my
team more than feeling the need to check
in every hour you're literally telling
people you can't do this without me I
have to be on every email you know so so
I'm really good when I decide to
disconnect to completely disconnect from
work and I I i understand that ideas I I
recognize that you know we talk about
work-life balance you know work in life
are not opposing forces its balance is
the wrong analogy you know I'm the same
person at home as I am at work it's just
different clothes in a different table I
sit at right and so and so what I try
and do is recognize that it's all my
life and there's no difference and where
I am and what I'm doing and so what I'm
trying to do is live a balanced life in
general and I work to ensure that
creative things are very much a part of
it that can be making things but that oh
that oh that can also be going to see
things I think it's very important for
people to take time off to look at art
see theater you know do whatever your
where your thing is I think need to
engage with something that challenges
your brain in a way that it doesn't
challenge you every single day so that
you see the world differently I have
many many ideas sitting in places they
don't
expect to have ideas
[Music]